a new warning about a rare inflammatory
syndrome tied to the corona virus in
children more than 330 cases have been
reported and at least four children have
died and now doctors say it could also
affect young adults CBS News senior
medical correspondent dr. Tara Narula
joins us Tara good morning to begin with
what our doctors learning about this new
development well Anthony by and large we
are still calling this syndrome a
disease or syndrome that affects
children and teenagers in fact the case
definition by the CDC requires that an
individual be less than the age of 21
now that's not to say that we may not
see sporadic cases or emerging cases in
individuals that are over 21 that's
really a cut-off that's a little bit
arbitrary in the sense that we know that
our biology and physiology doesn't
change tremendously between 21 23 and 24
so as we see some of these cases that
fit the other clinical manifestations
emerging in a little bit of an older
population the case definition of may
change I think it just fits with what
we're seeing with this virus is that
we're learning more and more each day
and really what this does is alert adult
cardiologists like myself an internist
to be aware if they see somebody with
some of these symptoms and signs to be
on high alert you may want to refer them
and and you may want to learn your
health department remind folks what the
symptoms are tara so primary symptoms
are going to be fever moderate or high
fever that lasts for several days
abdominal symptoms and children so
nausea vomiting diarrhea a rash
bloodshot eyes and then worsening
symptoms might be things like chest pain
or shortness of breath or lethargy or
confusion all of those should prompt
parents to pick up the phone call their
pediatrician and potentially take them
to an emergency room if necessary
ideally one that has a pediatric
intensive care unit
all right Tara dr. Tara Narula thank you
very much